hey gang my name is Sam basher and
welcome to the new rock stars the place
where your nerdy dreams come true today
I'm here to talk about ant-man
and the Wallace it's second installment
in the Ant Man franchise yep it's
franchise now and this marks the 20th
the film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe hot dog with these films we've
come to expect a post-credits scene or
two and I'm happy to report that there
are post-credit scenes named and the
wasp yes scenes let's break them down
should go without saying but there will
be spoilers in this video for ant-man
and the wasp all of the MCU Marvel
comics and more anyhoo is those first up
we get them made credit scene now this
is pretty important to see where ant-man
is that during the events of the Destiny
saw that word online basically during
the events of the end of Avengers
infinity war at the end of this film
Janet Van Dyne has returned to our realm
and has slight healing abilities they're
a little confusing if I can be honest it
seems more like she can only really heal
ghosts in her condition and they also
seem to possibly be a one-time thing
since the Scott is on his way down to
the quantum realm to suck up some more
of that quantum healing energy for
ghosts condition after he successfully
NAB's some of this Martinelli's
sparkling quantum juice he requests for
an extraction but there's no response we
see that hope Janet and Hank have all
been removed from the universe and Scott
his trapped down in the quantum realm
now my guess is that he's probably kept
one of those blue tabs on him you
remember that makes stuff grow from the
first movie or possibly can use his new
fancy regulator in his new suit to him
big himself back up to our reality
honestly if I was going back into the
quantum realm after being trapped there
previously I would keep a few of those
babies handy now could that healing
energy have anything to do with a
vengence 3d warp art too I'm sure
oh really but Scott being trapped in the
quantum realm or using quantum realm to
help stop Thanos there are some
possibilities there we actually have
some videos on it on this channel which
you should go check out also worth
asking because Scott was in the quantum
realm did that actually stop him from
being erased from existence possibly
maybe that will come into play in the
next Avengers film or maybe he was just
lucky but unlucky because he was down in
the quantum realm and might be stuck who
knows now the post credits scene is more
of a stinger than an actual scene we are
back in Scott and Louise's house and we
see an emergency broadcast on the TV
after the
which this kind of felt a lot more like
a zombie apocalypse movie than a Marvel
movie also during the scene it was a
little hard to tell when I was watching
it but possibly someone could have just
been dusted as well you know he erased
possibly in lluís that would make me
real bummed large so possibly it could
just have been an empty house or was it
it wasn't there's something there we
actually hear drums in the background
during the scene the camera turns to
reveal that the and that was tasked with
wearing Scott's ankle tracker is still
there drumming away doing his everyday
duties just like Scott Wood felt a
little weird to me being honest but
after that we do get the ant-man and the
wasp will return line on the screen but
there's at least a question mark appears
at the end of that sentence a man and a
wasp will return is this signaling that
maybe these characters may never return
they'll come back we know this they're
set photos of ant-man in Avengers 4 but
hey you know we got to play along a
little bit it makes it more fun when we
watch Avengers infinity War part 2 but
any who's those will have to wait and
see but let's throw it to you guys what
do you think will happen to Scott in the
quantum realm how will he factor into
infinity War part 2 let me know your
theories down below or on twitter at Sam
bash or like this video subscribe for
more content hit that Bell icon to get
notifications whenever a new video goes
live from us I love you guys I'll see ya
next time bye boy
[Music]